my cloth is about democratizing fashion
it's taking the direction of fashion out
of the hands of an elite group and
putting it back in the hands of the
consumer my name is JP a lot I'm a 2004
graduate of the MS IT program and i'm a
senior software architect for modcloth
started by eric and susan coger Susan
had started the company to fulfill her
love of vintage clothing so she was
purchasing lots of bitches things and
had more clothes and she could actually
use so she turned it to a business
selling the great finds that she
discovered two people over the Internet
my job at modcloth is a senior software
architect my goal is to help the
development teams come up with
innovative solutions faster we use a lot
of different services we are a very
social company we're oriented towards
things like Facebook Twitter we do lots
of contests build strong community ties
across these different things there's
the modcloth blog where we give our take
on fashion and what's going on today
community has been really huge from
modcloth I mean we're really a very
community centric organization a lot of
what we do is spread by word of mouth
both physically and in the virtual world
one of our big programs right now is be
the buyer the goal of be the buyer is to
help modcloth decide what should we be
selling and so it uses the community to
come in take a look at a set of outfits
and decide what should my loft be doing
the exposure to so many good people I
mean I think the classes I took there
were top-notch the professor's were
excellent I got a lot of depth from the
different topics they were talking along
they were always very friendly and
helpful to talk to you so if you had
questions or one continued conversations
they were always there to support you
and kind of feed that along they also
the good rich mix of people who were
there from academia and from business so
there was a lot of professors and
students who were out there
professionally as well so not just in
academia so they have that good breath
of perspective modcloth is a great
example of the multidisciplinary nature
of CMU just because we have so many
different aspects and while we have a
strong creative team we have a strong
technology team and we try and marry the
two together in a really strong way I
mean CMU is a hotbed of innovation there
was a lot of interesting technology a
lot of interesting people and a good mix
between the two so a lot of things
spring forth which is because you have a
lot of bright people who are happy to
collaborate work together and build
something better
you